donc au vu de ce que je voulais c'est
une remarque toute personnelle que je
vais vous faire même si les policiers
d'élite du j'espère et les gendarmes
d'élite qui appartiennent au gign et qui
sont détachés pour emploi où j'espère me
craignent vous me craignent et je suis
assez inquiet pour la sécurité du
président de la république en effet de
mémoire
il n'y a jamais eu aucun incident avec
aucun officier de sécurité du j'espère
pour la plupart sont des camarades avec
qui on s'entend bien
j'ai fait à peu près la même chose que
vous que pardon mais j'ai changé de
fonction un moment en arrivant à
l'elysée
mais j'ai toujours conservé des liens je
devais manger avec eux j'ai salle de
sport pas forcément l'assemblée
nationale sa salle de sport avec eux au
tir avec eux on passe du beaucoup de
temps avec eux on passe beaucoup de
temps avec eux quand on est à la
chefferie de cabinet on passe
principalement du temps avec eux j'ai
jamais eu aucun problème et j'ai été
abasourdi par les propos d'une personne
qui s'est offert une tribune médiatique
ici en racontant absolument n'importe
quoi et qui si elle avait été dans son
rôle et qui s'était vraiment passé ce
type de problème je suis pas très
inquiet sur le fait qu'elle l'aurait
fait savoir avant par la voix de presse
comme c'est l'habitude pour ces
personnes là j'ai jamais vu un article
de presse
un indiscret dans quelques magazines que
ce soit quelque journal type le canard
enchaîné ou le journal le point que dans
lequel on dit que monsieur b nana
terrorise les gens c'est pas vrai alors